look
it's so hard to compete at the level
that jordan clyde drexer and these guys
did
if people think
that when jordan's at the height of his
career
that he's also studying up on
geopolitical issues and domestic issues
the guy just had some self-awareness
like i'm gonna stay in my lane
i'm a basketball player right now why
don't y'all go ask
the politicians or
the the historians or activists or
whatever why are you asking me as a
basketball player and it's one of those
selfish things that we in the media did
because we all
this generation the generation of sports
journalists that didn't
get to cover muhammad ali
didn't get to cover
uh the impact of the vietnam war and the
civil rights movement on america
those of us that didn't we want to redo
it and we want to turn lebron james into
muhammad ali and i've said this and
many many times
lebron james is a basketball player he's
not that smart listen to him talk
uh listen go read his twitter feed his
instagram he can barely spell but y'all
think
this guy is some kind of uh
thought leader public intellectual
whatever
and then the number one thing because i
you know his lack of
grammar and all that i could almost deal
with that but what what the media
won't deal with is that
muhammad ali whether we like the nation
of islam or not he was connected and
controlled by a religious sec
and elijah muhammad malcolm x whether we
like them or not
very smart people
ahead of the curve they control muhammad
ali said what they told him to say and
did what they told him to do at that
time lebron james ain't connected to
nobody but nike and phil knight phil
knight is not elijah muhammad or malcolm
x
and so who's
who who's advised adam mendelson or and
i know adam mendelson the pr guy that
works behind but he ain't malcolm x or
elijah muhammad
expecting any of these these athletes
can barely keep up with their baby mamas
how the hell are they going to keep up
with what's going on in the rest of the
world
uh
it's just it's
we keep putting them in this position we
keep oh who gonna be the next muhammad
ali and and and we have to accept those
days are gone
the athletes today
make millions of dollars
live in gated communities
next to people who look like dave rubin
and they're not
in the hood they're not connected to the
working class
black americans or white americans the
way they used to be
these are the elites they've been led
into the club
that's why they go through these little
rituals uh
of putting dresses on like russell
westbrook and everybody go through these
humiliation rituals uh so they can be
led into the club they're not speaking
for the working class person anymore
they're speaking for nike they're
speaking for china they're speaking for
their pocketbooks
we need to cut it out
asking these guys to do things they're
incapable of doing i almost feel sorry
for them it's like
it it would almost be like uh
if somebody asked hey spend the night at
mcdonald's and never eat a double filet
of fish sandwich
it's not gonna happen today it's not
gonna happen i do i do like the filleto
fish that tartar sauce it's tangy
it's delicious if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about the media instead of non-stop
yelling check out our media playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out the full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell